Добрий день! Мене звати Петро Наконечний
Я директор Вищого професійного училища
№33 міста Києва
У моєму закладі навчається 670 учнів-
випускників 9 та 11 класів,
які обрали для себе переважно професію
кухаря, кондитера або перукаря.
Термін навчання в закладі складає від
6 місяців для груп
які здійснюють перепідготовку або
підвищення кваліфікації,
і для випускників шкіл від 1,5 до 3
років навчання
Перш за все, тому що вони мають
достатній рівень практичних навичок вже
під час навчання в училищі
Практику проходять на підприємствах
міста Києва - в кафе, ресторанах та
салонах краси.
Загалом маємо більше 70 партнерів.
Практика на підприємсвтві є оплачуваною.
Вони отримують від 4 тис гривень.
Для випускників 11 класів та дорослих
ми пропонуємо освіту з елементами
дуальної форми навчання.
Вона передбачає, що 30% процес
проходить в навчальному закладі,
а 70% - на виробництві
Групи на 100% працевлаштовуються
Навчатись у закладі профосвіти -
комфортно. Ось на такому обладнанні ми
навчаємо кухарів та кондитерів.
А на такому - перукарів та манікюрників.
Завдяки реформі профосвіти вже
найближчим часом ми зможемо:
підвищити кваліфікацію викладачів
та майстрів за новими стандартами
оновити і адаптувати навчальні плани
і програми до вимог ринку праці.
отримати більше варіантів для співпраці
з бізнесом
Зараз 7 українських областей беруть
участь у програмі ЄС EU4Skills, яка
підтримує реформу профосвіти в Україні.
Напрацьовані результати зможуть
використовувати усі заклади по Україні
та підвищити якість підготовки учнів.
Якщо ви мрієте реалізувати свій талант у
професію - вступайте у профтехосвіту!
В Україні можна отримати близько 690
різних професій!
У 2020 році вступна кампанія
розпочнеться у червні
Вступники подають до приймальних
комісій такі документи
заяву
оригінал або копію свідоцтва про
закінчення 9-го або 11-го класу
6 фотокарток 3х4
медичну довідку
копії документів, що підтверджують
право на пільги, якщо такі є.
Подаючи документи, вступники
пред'являють паспорт чи ID-картку
Всі деталі щодо вступу у заклади
профосвіти є на сайті Міністерства
освіти і науки та сайтах закладів освіти
Чекаємо на вас у закладі профтехосвіти,
для того, щоб допомогти отримати
професію мрії!